سائق القطارات اربكت ترتيبات سفر الناس في
بريطانيا فول عنا من توقف خط رحلته اكثر
من مره مطره الى تغيير مسار رحلته التي
امتدت لسعد ليجد نفسه اخيرا عالقا من دون
وسيله نقل بديله للوصول الى وجهته
النهائيه
من ادمر الى مانشستر لزياره عائليه
استغرقت ثمان ساعات على متنقارن ومحاولته
وصول الى بيت توقفت في يورك اما رحله قطار
من هناك الى لندن فكانت جيده ولكن الان لا
توجد قطارات للذهاب الى مطار لوتون علي ان
ابحث الان عن حافله او سياره
لبعض سائق القطارات لا خيار لديهم كما
يقولون سوى الاضراب عن العمل لاعاده مدير
شركاتهم لمطالبتهم بزياده اجرهم وتحسين
الظروف عملهم
70 كم فينيس لا نريد ان ينتزعج الناس ولكن
للاسف موقف الحكومه المتعنت يزيد من
ايرباك الناس وانزعجهم على المستوى الشخصي
يفقد سائق قوى القطارات الماله عندما
يضربون عن العمل
نقابه اذلف التي تمثل 96% من سائق
القطارات في المملكه المتحده ارغمت 5 10
شركه تدير رحلات القطار على تعليق خدماتها
في اضراب قد لا يكون الاخيره مع غياب اي
مؤشر لحل نزاع المغربي لا اضراب جديدا
جدولا لسائق القطارات لكن نقبتهم ستجتمعوا
لمناقشه الخطوه المقبله لاشعار اداره شبكه
البنيه التحتيه للسكك الحديديه بايام
اضرابات اخرى قبل اسبوعين على الاقل من
موعدها مصطفى زاروه العربيه من محطه كينج
رولز